je suis un chef pro choix et je veux
toujours défendre les doigts pour les
femmes de choisir pour elle même point
final on va aussi examiner les doigts de
conscience pour les tno infirmières et
nos médecins particulièrement avec
l'aide médicale à mourir est-ce que
professionnels de la santé peut refuser
de donner des soins parce que ça va à
l'encontre de ses croyances religieuses
ou personnel
[Musique]
la réponse est oui mais il ya des
conditions à respecter et ces conditions
love varie selon les règles qui sont
établies par le collège des médecins
dans chaque province au québec par
exemple l'article 24 du code de
déontologie dit que le médecin qui
refuse de prodiguer un avortement ou
l'aide médicale à mourir doit offrir aux
patients de l'aider dans la recherche
d'un autre médecin en ontario aussi le
patient doit être référé ce qui est
clair si quelqu'un a besoin d'une série
tels services et si le médecin ne peut
pas le livre et le fournir le médecin
eut le travail de santé droit trouver
quelqu'un qui peut le faire mais ce
n'est pas une obligation partout au pays
au manitoba par exemple un médecin qui
refuse de prodiguer des soins pour ses
croyances personnelles n'a pas besoin de
référé le patient pour les infirmières
au québec l'objection de conscience
s'applique seulement dans le cas de
l'aide médicale à mourir n'est rien
n'est prévu spécifiquement pour les
interruptions de grossesse